I'm doing a lot of food stuff now trying
to on this diet and trying to get
healthy that I found out this is such
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that food has been my my
friend mmm it's it's been yeah my one of
my best friends I mean since I was a kid
I remembered getting food and coming
home because I didn't have any friends
and I didn't have any father or anybody
and I'd be alone all the time and I
would get food and sit in front of the
TV with the food like my pal and I still
do that now like when I a pizza comes I
want to wait until the pizza comes to my
friend gets there and then we start the
movie right like you're not gonna start
your show they have the pizza there it's
part of the whole experience
is the whole experience and you think
about the show that you're about to
watch in context of I'll have a nice
pizza in front of me it's so weird how
food and I never realized food any
function I go to food is my best pal
every party I go to a movie anywhere I
go my party do you in the supermarket or
all your friends are I just go in
high-five the hot dog you [ __ ] I've
tried it's sad it is sad I mean I'd
probably not that uncommon yeah but do
you think it has an addiction is the
word it's the worst because you have to
eat well not even that but like like
heroin like to give heroin act like drug
addicts so much credit for booting the
drug and it's like it's a little easier
cuz it's illegal and you can avoid
heroin right it's very easy to avoid
avoid it but it's also against the law
yeah like there's a lot of risk again
and there's no there's no fat [ __ ]
police there's also not the foodie
equivalent of heroin like there's not a
community of people if you've eaten a
whole cake I know you don't know
divinium I'm saying like there's not
there's not a socially acceptable
community of people that just appreciate
heroin you know what I mean whereas with
foodies it's like it's a culture right
let's not look down a job I'm a foodie
it's like the it is this culture you
don't say I'm a junkie proudly be
telling I'm a foodie oh this guy really
understands the palate yeah Netflix puts
out like foodie docs and it's like oh I
aspire to be like that I
others mean that I'll probably never be
able to eat food like that again doesn't
bother me it does make me sad that I'm
losing my friends but you know what you
look at like this you've used up all
your good time like you've gotten more
than your share like I look at it like
that with whatever it is I can't do if
it's I can't act out sexually I've
gotten more than most people get in ten
lifetimes oh yeah my greed is the issue
not my lack of getting well it was a
culmination to where it came in I would
always get you know I would always go to
my food addiction and then come off of
it for years and right that's what you
talk about your multiple yeah multiply
sex fat's right yeah but this one when I
had the kid I got so stressed and
anxiety
the year I I had a baby I sold my
apartment in New York I bought it I
rented a place and then I bought a place
to move it was like all the all the
transition [ __ ] that is the crazy I did
in a year right and my whole life was so
[ __ ] up and stressed out that I just
buried my need to hang out with your
friends you need to find your best
friend and they were there for me yeah
oh my god hey wise how are you ruffles
curlicues ah yeah so this one was a sort
of look now and be like okay I'm
probably never gonna have shitty snacks
again sure yeah well you have new
friends have a baby carrot they're
lovely
okay I love a nice baby care what a
friend and you realize Orange this bunch
of them and you sit there and you
realize like in those moment you have to
stop yourself from realizing my new
friends are nowhere near as cool this is
your new friends who are boring like
this is what I was eating yesterday when
I'm home right I had I was having little
baby carrots and I would wrap them in a
piece of thinly sliced low-sodium deli
turkey meat thinly slice wrapping it and
I would have one plain almond and I
would dip it in mustard and put the
entire Treat in my mouth
that's your new friend it's my new
friend and you have to sit there you
like when you make new friends that
you're like you know what maybe right
now they're not as fun and maybe it's
not as unpredictable and wild but these
friends are better for me these friends
would make me a better pilot I was I
came back from
how long were you there for I was there
for seven days and I really felt
different in my body why like my body
was [ __ ]
oh just I was doing things that I've
been to a rib of twenty years I was
doing a lot of the things that I've done
a long vacation now I've been on and off
who do you like the Big Lebowski or
something such a good rapper otherwise
this is your friend
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]